So we've spoken a little bit about getting the content into Unreal Engine, how about
when we want to export from Unreal Engine.
So we can still use the FBX version, we can keep or remove the mesh and the information
that we're looking at here is vertex color, LODs, collision and animation mesh.
So first time importing, you want to click the import inside the content browser, you
can either do this through the content browser or you can go to file import and you want
to select the FBX option.
The first time you import a whole new character, you'll need to import the mesh and the skeleton
together.
So every subsequent import doesn't need the skeleton because Unreal will already have that
information but just make sure you do those together on the first import and skeleton
mesh needs to be checked and import mesh needs to be checked too.
So there's an image there of what we mean but just make sure skeleton mesh and import
mesh are both ticked on your import FBX options here.
So when we're importing animations, you can set the animation length, so the exported
time, do you want the whole thing, do you want the animated time or do you just want
to leave the animated parts here.
Are you setting your range so you can manually select the frames that you want to import
here.
You've got the sample rate and also import bone tracks.
So you've got a lot of options at your disposal here.
A helpful important note would be the transform so you can compensate for any incorrect rotations.
So again, like we said before, you really should be fixing this in your DCC app to make
sure everything is one to one with Unreal Engine in your external package before you
import.
We can override transforms here for example but it'll just lead to headaches later on
if you need to reimport anything and you forget that you've set certain issues and also just
any scaling issues.
Just make sure ideally importing at a uniform scale of one is just the best default here.
Some miscellaneous options to talk about here, you could force front X axis just to
make sure that, say for example if you're using Blender and setting the X axis there,
you could tick that and you can convert the scene unit as well.
So when we're importing new animations for old skeletons, you would just go ahead and
import like normal.
You can select the skeleton you want and choose the animation length but just know if the
skeleton is exactly the same then this should be a very straightforward process.
If not, you may have to retarget it using the new retargeting tools which we briefly
went over before.
If you want to reimport an animation, you can just right click in the menu and reimport
the editor for more options.
So you'll see different dialog boxes here that you can use to reimport and you'll get
your import settings and just reimport using these settings and that should allow you for
some quick reimport from the base mesh there.
So we've got the skeleton mesh editor on the left details panel.
You can right click on the asset in the content browser and the skeleton mesh editor in the
top menu there.
If you are using animations from the library, so from the marketplace maybe, you can add
these to the project directly.
So you can just click add to project on any animation packs that you have or you can just
migrate the specific animations.
If you already had that project open and you want to bring them over to another project,
sorry, you can right click on the content, you can go to asset actions and migrate and
you can migrate these animations over to a different project and they'll bring the information
with them or you can just add them fresh to a new project.
So you're probably more likely than not to find yourself needing to be retargeting these
animations and it likely comes with its own skeleton in that instance, but it is possible
and very straightforward process to do.